how's it looking today so here's the
deal I recently let the person in front
of me decide what haircut I got because
everyone on the internet was letting the
person in front of them decide what they
ate and I thought hair was more intense
but now I need to take it to the next
level tattoo I'm not gonna get the
tattoo though because for that I'm gonna
make my friend Clark do it
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't like that look on your face you
ready for the tattoo no today's the day
we're doing we're doing it I thought you
were just joking oh you're not actually
going to do it oh no yeah I mean yeah
let's do it
you're still down yeah wait a minute why
did you say yes this video by the way I
didn't think anyone would agree but I
love tattoos because for me there are
way to commemorate a memory or a moment
in my life like when I travel I like to
get a tattoo I got this tattoo in
Montreal
you know I thought it'd be fun to get a
tattoo to commemorate buzzfeed I'll look
at whatever it goes a little bunny like
Oh Eric and BuzzFeed know the weird
stuff that he made me do
I've never actually even seen someone
get a tattoo so I'm just excited to be
in like a part a tattoo parlor and
experience this yeah I think the
premises we just get there and whatever
the last tattoo Dave's gonna give you
what if it's like somebody getting a
tattoo to commemorate like a lost loved
ones yeah like a grandma rip like
Phyllis like that's gonna be really sad
let's do this how are you honestly
feeling I don't know why I trust you so
much but we've done a lot of videos
together and you no matter like how bad
things have been you've always kind of
had my back so I really don't think he'd
put me in a situation that would turn
out badly for me so I feel fun honestly
I'm stoked
I feel bad nowadays I grew up in a very
like Baptist home where like your body
is a temple so tattoos are frowned upon
so my mom found out about my first
tattoo she was devastated and I just
kept getting him okay with him now or
she's still she likes them now and now
that she like knows now that they're not
like the word Veritas above my better
like the fact like it's my art Corgi or
my cat or a Bible verse like she's okay
with it I don't I doubt she'll love this
video unless it's something really
beautiful or maybe it's like a skull
praying who knows but I guarantee you
Clark
you think the video that we're shooting
right now he's going to tattoo parlor
and he's going to get the same tattoo as
the person that was like right before
him what do you think about that by the
way Clark you're in luck because I did
think about pranking you and I was just
gonna ask the guy to give a tattoo that
said Eric or like I love Eric but then I
decided that's not as fun of a video
could you imagine
[Music]
what's up what's up how's it going good
to see you
this is Clark by the way hi how you
doing
[Music]
but on idea okay plan is we'll just
figure out where to get the patio are
you getting worried out no I like how
thoughtful they are about the placement
of where it's gonna go I don't want to
be too difficult but also I don't want
to like just slide something anyway so
I'm glad they're thinking about how it's
gonna you know how it's gonna looking
all that will hurt maybe go over there
and don't look because I gotta make this
like a one-person this is so stressful
what do you think so far yeah it's
exciting dude this is awesome
come on is the bravest man I've ever met
in my entire life it takes serious
cojones to do something like this
how long have you been doing tattoos
like since last more you started last
month yeah get out of here I can help a
aspiring artists
[Music]
are you sure you're gonna do for him
this one
don't play like that mark are you
comfortable with full frontal nudity
images on your body only if it's male
genitalia I've never been in a tattoo
parlor before first seen anyone get a
tattoo that sound the sound of the tag -
gun that makes my heart like race like
with excitement really I am ready to
rock forever means forever right this is
for you
it's so detailed try not to move too
much when you talk like just be like
aware of your movements and
[Music]
do you not get tattoos because of your
acting career I was raised to be like
scared of tattoos to think tattoos were
bad and stuff I used to draw doodles on
myself all the time and like a love it
for a minute and then be like I need to
get this off right away I don't know how
you tell where like the stencil is and
where the ink is that's what separates
them from the [ __ ]
[Music]
so the person that got this was as a
custom designer was as a designer you'd
already created I mean it was based on a
photo but she wanted it to look more
cute and like less apart she wanted it
to look more cute and less darn this
feels very on-brand you take any more
guesses at what it is I really I really
AM clueless as to what is what it is
because I purpose it I didn't look at
your Instagram page I didn't look it
like the art that the studio does so the
only cues that I'm going off of our
snakes on this wall instincts on that
wall I saw somebody getting into eagle
when I came in
[Music]
is it done yeah yeah I'm gonna check it
out yeah we're ready to look wait
where's the mirror all right let's go
check it out let's go check it out what
do you what are you thinking what are
you feeling I feel excited I feel like I
don't know what I have but now I'm ready
to see it
[Laughter]
penguins are my second favorite animal
next to Courtney's are they really yes I
have a penguin painting in my room I
have a pink with a lamp yeah I couldn't
come so bad that was not what I was
expecting at all I think it kind of
looks cool on the shoulder yeah like
it's a dancing thing oh you did it baby
we did it man
I watched to do it I thought it could
have got a lot worse like when I walked
in there was taxidermy everywhere
there's a bear with the skeleton and in
its mouth like I was not expecting it
people at all oh I love it yeah I'm so
glad you did this and agree to this and
that everything worked out well and the
experience was great for you so um so
what's next what's next yeah what's next
is
[Music]
trying to forget budgets that we met
yesterday
Oh